Oh gabbo gabbo gabbo gabbo gabbo gabbo
gabbo gabbo go go go oh god Oh Kapoor go
go go well then good evening everyone my
name is Gloria Borger and welcome to
prio news the most reputable respected
brand new site that's the sign of the
Apocalypse oh my god
not again I can't do another one god
dammit ah the ad pocalypse too is upon
us why is everyone talking about this
keep watching this video and I will
break it down but first a very important
admin role will show here oh god it's
the apocalypse not God what are we gonna
do for tonight pulls ads over YouTube oh
god not for tonight Nestle pull ads from
YouTube Oh God not Nestle the most
ethical company of all time tasty dish
knee pulls ads from YouTube what am I
gonna do without Disney ads huh ads that
I'm already not getting on my videos
with dammit
This Is It this is the end of pew news
they're just gonna have to buy the
mercury that is available on a limited
time only I guess that's the only way to
for this channel to survive another ad
pocalypse if everyone buys at least 10
pairs then maybe I will survival now I
had pocalypse - why are people talking
about this why are ads pulling away from
YouTube to understand this very complex
situation we need to go back yeah the
way I first heard about this was in
regards to another channel called girls
Couture Club which we will not show
there no pictures for those of you don't
know girls Couture is a YouTube channel
it's kind of like a modeling agency I
don't think at least it's just a group
of them young girl models now if you
check out their channel page the most
popular videos are all bikini related so
already that's kind of disturbing and at
the same time as people pointed out that
this
Cannell exist to regular family friendly
I think at least gaming channels got
shut down by YouTube out of nowhere
saying so my channel just went down for
Community Guidelines strikes for sexual
content y'all into Pokemon or something
that's right mystic seven who uploads
pokemon gold videos got his channel
terminate him same thing happened to
violence Ki bum 94 woke up with my
youtube channel terminated great
fantastic bielski you upload clubpenguin
video so people started wondering why
did this happen is it because there has
CP in the title CP which of course in
Pokemon memes combat points but in other
terms it could also mean add a file no
wait
cat porn and then you have Club Penguin
which stands for CP as well as pointed
out by Emperor lemon YouTube vs CP
pokemon goat
no Club Penguin bikinis ah YouTube logic
everyone now this doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with the ad
pocalypse
but I think it's important for context
after all now I don't know where this
guy name what it is Matt what it is made
a video and he talked about how YouTube
is facilitating the ad sexual
exploitation of children and it's being
monetized parentheses 2019 always
helpful to know what year it is
so what Matt pointed out was that if you
click on videos on YouTube a certain
type of videos you will eventually enter
this click hole where YouTube will
recommend to you videos of really young
girls wearing skinny clothes or maybe
doing gymnastics or something like that
the more you click on it the more those
videos will be recommended to you and
I'd be lying if I said I was surprised I
mean this is how it works on YouTube
YouTube wants you to stay on the website
as long as possible so the way the
algorithm works is that if you watch a
certain type of content for a long time
YouTube is going to recommend more of
that content to you now the irony of
this is that YouTube's algorithm has
been serving pedophiles videos of young
girls I mean it's not funny but it's
just messed up another thing Matt
pointed out was that if you check the
comments on these videos there's a bunch
of people writing kind stamps now this
is a way for people in these pedophile
rings to help each other out to find the
explicit sexually explicit part or what
can be interpreted as such in these
videos now these videos in Sutton in
themselves are just innocent videos of
girls they're not doing anything in
particular but there might be like that
one point where maybe they show a little
bit more or something like that and
through the youtube comment section
people find those parts more easily
models have pointed out how the
hypocrisy that these videos are actually
monetized as well showing ads on them
and the Apocrypha being that YouTube's
constantly be monetizing its creators
while serving ads on this type of
content it's kind of annoying but I
think there's a bigger issue at hand
here which is of course this clickhole
of videos now up until this point I'm
completely aboard with Matt and I agreed
like this is just completely disgusting
something obviously needs to be done
about this but somehow this whole thing
became let's try and get ads to pull
away from YouTube and let's try and make
that happen and then I think what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to start
contacting McDonald's and things like
that if you go to my video YouTube is
facilitating the sexual exploitation of
children in the description I've
included all the social media contact
information for every brand that appears
in my video and will I it worked
advertisers started pulling out from
YouTube because of this now a lot of
people asked why is pulling ads from
YouTube stopping pedophiles well
obviously it doesn't it might raise more
awareness or urgency to YouTube but
other than that it just seems like
you're just gonna hurt everyone on the
website it's there is it the right way
to go about it now a side effect of this
became that not just advertisers pulled
up courts but channels that uploaded
family-friendly content with their kids
in it got their videos to monetize
Jessica balling ever who pointed out
that the videos of her five-year-old son
got the monetized
and not just the monetized but she all
the comments on these videos were
disabled as well YouTube responded to
this saying that out of abundance of
caution some videos that include minors
and
at risk of predatory comments may have
comments disabled this is only related
to content that may invade your minors
more info they also recommended that if
you have videos with minors in them you
should hold off comments and review
which honestly seems pretty sensible if
you ask me YouTube also said that they
terminated 400 channels and reported
illegal comments to the law enforcement
which is great but people were furious
people were genuinely outraged saying
this is the end of YouTube because of
this response that YouTube made with
regards to the action that we've taken
even if your video is suitable for
advertisers inappropriate comments could
result in your video receiving limited
or no act so comments on YouTube could D
monetize for the Creator which seems
pretty crazy if you think about it and a
lot of people who are not happy about
this saying YouTube is now officially
the monetizing videos in the comments
section how easy it is now to rekha
YouTube verse career just leave insults
on their videos and they get punished
for it and a lot of people echoed this
sentiment basically going well so what
you're saying is that if I'm powerful
enough troll I could single-handedly
destroy someone's livelihood and you
don't see anything wrong with that I
think for the first time in a long time
I'm on the side well YouTube this is
obviously a swift and short-term
solution because people like Matt who
just want to see the site burn and are
contacted advertisers and doing all this
stuff to to just cause as much damage
and havoc as possible they obviously
need to act quickly the videos that got
demonetized from Jessica are gymnastic
videos of a five year old I'm sorry but
maybe you can live without them being
monetized it seems kind of questionable
already even if they are advertiser
friendly given the circumstance
obviously they could be problematic I
think I have the right to talk about
this because pretty much exact same
thing happened to me there's in a
different context of me making jokes
okay it's not the exact same thing but
basically I made jokes about Jews and
then you had actual aunt who sent my
taking it seriously and that caused a
bunch of problems for me and
it's kind of similar in a really weird
way it's annoying how minority of
disgusting idiots are causing so much
problem but that's the reality of the
situation I think there's a larger issue
at hand here where it goes back to the
beginning with the girls Couture stuff
where you have girls in bikinis very
young what do you do with that are you
gonna allow that to be monetized from
now on and where do you draw the line on
that it's family-friendly no longer
family-friendly hmm they're not setting
a precedent by removing comments or de
monetizing these videos it's not
something that's gonna affect everyone
on the site it's clearly something
they've done just to act swiftly at a
time when it's necessary and to be
honest I appreciate that YouTube does
that so before everyone freaks out and
see YouTube is over no it isn't calm
down they are working on and I trust
that they are actually now something
worth actually getting outraged about
the sub gap PewDiePie versus T Series
now obviously I'm completely impartial
in this matter I don't care who wins or
comes down on top t gay
t gay but last night the sub gap closed
now of course viewer discretion is
advised what I'm about to show you is
extremely disturbing that's right these
series you thought you had me the job
YouTube those slides son of a guns
decided to delete 20,000 subscribers
immediately from my channel the sub gap
was at 22,000 and then very quickly they
took over T series actually past
PewDiePie in subscribers for 10 minutes
ten excruciating painful minutes but it
was necessary because now they got a
taste of what it means to be number one
and that's all you're ever gonna get TV
series they meant nothing because you
know what happened
even must came down from the sky and
hosted me review and now the sub gap is
at 55,000 and PewDiePie is rightfully at
number one again I'm not supposed to
give my opinion on that of course but he
deserves it goddamnit
Nix News Reggie the CEO of Nintendo
America had an announcement last night
hi Nintendo fans Reggie here by now you
may have heard the news yep I'm retiring
how old is Reggie's 57 years this this
guy is really retiring at 57 goddamn
alright Fairplay and just as you
understand that Nintendo always tries to
put smiles on faces well let me tell you
you put thousands of smiles on mine as I
head off in a couple of months to spend
more time with my wife my family and my
friends I'm handing over the controller
to the Doug Bowser in my April Doug will
become the new is his name Bowser Doug
Bowser that cannot be right Nintendo of
America's new boss dog powers are
quickly turning to memes oh my god oh my
god
Dawg Bowser don't do it Reggie he
tricked you he tricked you into early
retirement ask you with a name like
Bowser who better to hold the keys to
the Nintendo Castle what that's the
worst
Bowser is the bad guy there's Reggie not
know this does Reggie not know this in
April
I'll be dropping the title that's meant
so much to me president of Nintendo of
America but I'll retain one that means
even more Nintendo fan sorry boy and I'm
just kidding it's a very heartfelt
goodbye and not everyone shared this
sentiment Soulja Boy who claims that I
made him retire how could you Soulja Boy
disgusting aren't you supposed to be in
prison I'm starting a petition right now
to put Soulja Boy in jail because that
way you deserve to be funny tweet but
you shouldn't you be in jail yeah that's
right so
boy that's it for Peters hope you guys
enjoyed this episode if you did of
course check out merch you don't have to
of course like honestly like you don't
have to or anything got no way it's
that's it for me for now however for
Gabor Gabor Gabor
[Music]